good morning John okay I found out
something and I can't shut up about it
so you're gonna have to deal with me a
desert island is not a desert island by
which I mean a desert island can be lush
and covered with water with big
rainforest trees is not an island that
is a desert it is desert an adjective
that I have been using my whole life
without knowing that it exists desert
means uninhabited or deserted this word
des ERT has four different definitions
and two different pronunciations one
desert noun a place without much water
desert two adjectives uninhabited desert
verb where you abandon something like
you're a deserter and for desert noun
the thing you deserve another word I've
been using my whole life without knowing
it exists and I say you got your just
deserts I don't mean you got your tasty
after-meal treat in this case just means
like your fair and deserts means the
things you deserve but the just part of
this idiom is completely irrelevant
because every desert is something that
is just it is what you deserve
definition o8 all of this is to say
nothing of desert with the extra s the
delicious thing that you eat after
you're done with dinner this led me into
a place that was terrible and you won't
find out why until the very end but of
course it being English we have words
for all of these things we have words
for words that sound or look like each
other but don't mean the same thing so
there are three things here that words
might have in common there's the meaning
there's how they sound and there's how
they're spelled now in this situation
we're talking about words that all have
different meanings so I'm just gonna
discard that for now talk about the
suffixes that we use for words that have
different meaning but are pronounced the
same or are written the same when we're
talking about pronunciation we're
talking about how they sound so we use
the suffix phone and we're talking about
how they look we're talking about
writing so we use the suffix
Graff and then we have our prefixes we
have hetero for different and homo for
saying so a homophone is something that
sounds the same but has a different
definition and a home the graph is
something that looks the same but has a
different definition and then you have
the word that we talked about which is
hominem and that's when both of those
things are true so far this makes sense
it's not super easy to get your head
around but it makes sense hominem same
pronunciation same spelling but
different meaning like desert and desert
and all homonyms are also Homa phones
and homographs but some words are only
Homa phones and some words are only
homograft like desert and desert they
sound the same but they're spelled
different and this means that they are
also something called a hetero graph
meaning they look different and then my
friends there are things that are
spelled the same but sound different
Homa graphs like desert and desert these
things sound different they are header
of phones and they are called hetero
names this took me a half an hour of my
life to figure out why aren't they
called hetero phones John I'll see you
on Tuesday
also we recently did a thing where there
was a map and you could put a pin in it
and tell us where you live for when
we're going on tour and then it broke so
we had a bunch of pins and it was
beautiful
I really enjoyed looking at it but now
it is no longer useful data I don't know
what happened so there's a link to a
form in the description please fill it
out let us know where we should come
when we go on tour next we're gonna have
a weird and fantastic time wherever we
end up going but we need to know where
to go thanks